the m resort is going to be rocking
tomorrow night with a huge labor day
weekend concert which includes everclear
and one of our favorites elvis monroe
joining us now is brian hopkins and ben
carey from elvis monroe welcome back you
guys thanks bud thanks for having us
you've been in the studio many times
before and i don't think you ever told
us what what what's the meaning of the
name elvis monroe elvis monroe the
original uh
bass player in this band was matt nelson
ricky nelson's son really and uh it was
his joke a way of getting people to call
me elvis um and so having a nelson in
the band already and american pop
culture he said elvis and then we'll
just throw a dress on him and call him
marilyn monroe the matter is i look
better in the dress than brian does i've
seen you in a dress
how excited are you to be performing
live tomorrow night and resort with
everclear it feels amazing to get to
play
again to people and we've been as i told
you cameras are off we were we've been
on the road and so to be in our hometown
and get to play with everclear oh it's a
great guy he's one of
20 years and sharing the stage with him
again is going to be great and and the
end result is one of our favorite places
it's one of the first places we played
in london actually it was this place we
played in las
about 11 years ago and uh
feels like a homecoming you know yeah
and bad your backstory you were in life
house i'm sure you guys crossed every
claire's path at some point in the late
90s many shows together and even outside
of life house art is just such a
genuinely great dude and he's an amazing
music producer so we we connected on a
level outside a lifehouse just as people
just a good dude and we're happy to
share the stage with him he saved me
once i was out with my old band
and art everclear and cheap trick and
and we didn't have a back line he goes
you can play mine
saved us listen speaking of playing
you're gonna play your new song song
bird road you're gonna be the first band
performing in studio since prior to the
pandemics this is very big i'll let you
guys take it away it's elvis monroe
brand new song songbird road
[Music]
i find my own way
may not be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't need a compass to find my soul
you're all that i know
bleeding hard let me
[Music]
i am
everything i am
[Music]
lost on the dirty road i find my way
home you're all lined